foreign
Portland Oregon hi Justin Merry
Christmas
hey you guys too thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
hey um so we and my wife and I finished
maybe step two about eight months ago
and uh which included roughly forty
eight thousand dollars in student loan
debt congrats and
um so we didn't have any debt and
um
my wife found out a couple months ago
that she qualified for twenty thousand
dollars and the student loan forgiveness
program
and which how we didn't have any debt
and she qualified for that I have no
idea why that is or how that is
um so she applied and we were approved a
couple weeks ago we got a check from the
United States Treasury for forty eight
thousand dollars oh crap and I'm like
okay well that's a little odd first of
all we only qualify for twenty thousand
so why do we have a check for 48 well
there are there let's wait a minute stop
there has been no student loan
forgiveness that's right
well so so what they did is they put
your loan back on the books yep
that's exactly what they did
so they I looked into it and
um
they they reopened her student loans and
charted it the exact amount that's on
this check that we received yep they
gave you they gave you a refund because
you're because your debt was already
paid and you qualified for this and
maybe they I don't know I don't know why
they doubled it maybe they assumed you
that's the original balance uh the
original ah so they put it all back oh
these guys are Scoundrels man the these
so yeah
I mean they went from having no debt to
now having a debt of forty thousand two
hundred people I'll just send the checks
back and tell them to close the account
and don't apply for student loan
forgiveness again
okay now that was my question I didn't
want to cash it because I don't want to
be taxed on it this whole thing is it's
not taxable it's not taxable there's no
taxes on it but what what you may end up
doing is you may end up having to pay
some interest because you now have a
fifty thousand dollar loan on the books
again
my guess is you're going to have to cash
it and then make a payment and pay the
loan off again that's right
yeah and and the student loan uh
servicer they do not know what's going
on we've called three or four times and
we've gone three or four different
answers they're showing no balance
no they're showing the balance that the
check is for still okay yeah um but they
do know what's going on so they're
acting like they don't know what's going
to know what's going on they know they
now have a loan that they are charging
interest on again they are happy campers
send that money back
go go today yeah close that account
today and I'm afraid that your wife's
screwing around with this might have
cost you four or 500 interest we'll
we'll see when the Smoke Clears on this
hopefully not and that goes for anybody
Dave do if your loan is a zero balance
do not go back into debt to to possibly
get this money yeah it's it's too risky
there there's not enough information
going on with that and and we can listen
to a call like this and see they he
didn't even request the 48 000 they just
opened up the whole amount of the loan
back yeah it's very it's very Sinister
it's very nefarious what these folks are
doing and I don't like it and if I'm if
I'm y'all I'm not getting involved in it
you're debt free be debt free walk away
walk away walk away yeah so get you know
you're gonna have to treat this like you
have a 48 000 loan balance because you
do and you have 48 000 check in your
hand cause you do so my guess is you're
going to make a deposit of that you're
going to write a check and close the
loan out again and whatever period of
time this gyration has been going on
you're probably going to have some
interest due and um you might even have
a late charge because you haven't been
paying your payments properly yeah guys
don't let the lure of free money
lead somebody who's otherwise smart into
doing something stupid do not do not
fall for that wow
let's kind of back up about two steps
here's what exactly happened technically
okay there is no student loan
forgiveness program as of this date
facts period
there is not a loan forget the the Biden
uh student loan forgiveness program is
is under several lawsuits going before
The Supreme Court on February the 28th
the hearings begin they may go on for
months or years but they begin
to decide if Biden's student loan
forgiveness program is going to go
forward today it does not exist
okay so you do not need to apply for
something today that does not exist this
is just what his wife did was she said
my grandmother what big eyes you have
that's right thank you little Hood red
and Hyde oh my God this is a carrot that
started as a bright orange shiny carrot
dangling in front of our eyes but trust
me by the time this goes through the
Supreme Court and months and months and
maybe years of litigation is going to be
an old rotten carrot that's driven a lot
of us into making bad decisions well
what what his wife did
and bless your heart she was trying to
do something smart she was trying to get
money back
from a loan she'd already paid off that
she may qualify for if this does go
through when it does go through but they
don't have a mechanism
the government nor the student loan
provider does not have a mechanism to do
student loan forgiveness because it does
not exist today
yeah okay the court has not cleared it
there is not a program there it doesn't
exist and so what they did was they said
oh you really didn't mean to pay off
your student loans you'd like to keep
them there in case forgiveness comes
through so we're going to give you your
money back that you paid off the loan
and put the loan back on the books so
when and if forgiveness comes along
we'll be able to give you the
Forgiveness against of twenty thousand
against the forty eight thousand right
that's what that's what they did and if
people aren't careful that money is
going to be sitting there and whenever
interest starts back
people who aren't watchful that's a good
point there won't be any interest there
won't be but what is it March I told him
there might be interest charged on this
thing well if he lets it sit if you let
that money sit until forgiveness takes
place but I I did tell him there might
be interesting now and I was wrong not
yet not yet yeah that was a Miss but I
still want him to take that check and it
could be a late charge it could be a
late charge for not paying payments oh
oh well no payments right now but the
point is the point is if you're not
careful if you take your eye off the
ball in this situation that money will
be sitting in your account you will have
forgotten about it right because it's
just sitting there and you've got this
check that you're kind of holding on as
well waiting and and you're trusting
yourself to not spend that forty eight
thousand dollars during Christmas time
during inflation during the start of a
new year that is a very precarious
situation to put yourself in no way we
really it's been a hard year we really
need a vacation oh man and in my
cousin's wedding is coming up in the
Caribbean and we got to get a car you
know that car we have to get a car you
know we do and and and you know we need
it we need a new van for those twins
there's no question yeah that's the kind
of crap that's going to happen all over
America it's already happening yep
because they do not have a mechanism to
process your
student loan forgiveness check because
there is not a policy in place to do it
today that is approved it's in the
courts and those servicers can't wait to
issue your fake refund back in debt they
just got you they made you alone yep
they couldn't wait to do it
and they call it Dave a refund
that's what I hate they're calling it
they're they're they're they're they're
putting positive vocabulary around it so
it feels like we're getting some sort of
prize but there's no prize to be gotten
yet
well that's a prize but it's not one of
the trophies you want
oh Justin I'm sorry what a mess for you
honey yeah oh we're not making fun of
You Justin where's your wife we're
trying to tell these folks out here
you're trying to do it everything
everything under the heading student
loan if you just say that first
everything second says sucks this is the
Ramsey Show